It was harder than
we anticipated
and it was much,
much colder.
We're a team of six people.
Our goal is to determine
what the highest peak in Burma
is and then climb it.
Like to solve this fantastic
geographical mystery.
It never let up, just taken
down to, like, nothing and
how... how did that happen?
( applause )
I first learned of
Hkakabo Razi in 2001.
That's the name of the peak and
so for, you know, 15
years I've dreamt of
going to this place
in Northern Myanmar
the eastern edge
of the Himalayas
and exploring this mountain.
And finally in the Fall of 2014
this sort of imagined
expedition came to pass.
This is us, down to nothing
at the end of our trip.
One of the most incredible,
incredible adventures
I've ever been on in my life,
and that's saying a lot.
I've been on probably 40
different expeditions
all over the world.
In 2011, I led an expedition
of about 12 athletes
with North Face.
Conrad Anker was one of those.
And it was a really
amazing success
we all summited,
skied from the top and...
That led to an invite to go on
a National Geographic-North Face
supported expedition to Everest.
Mark Jenkins just happened
to be on the trip as well.
I'd never met him before.
He was coming in late.
We spent ten, ten days hiking
into base camp together.
And that where we
started talking about
all these adventures and
exploration that we'd done and
and Mark is incredibly
well traveled.
And the story of Burma
came up
and...
I didn't know the
Himalayas ended in Burma.
So, we started talking
about Hkakabo Razi and
Mark had actually
tried to go and
climb it when the
area was closed
and been, like, arrested
and all these crazy things
that Mark does.
As we got further into the climb
of Everest, and you can see here
this is heading
towards the summit
and the people and
the crowding.
It was just a stretch
from where I had started
as this adventurer in new places
and here was this
amazing mountain but
a lot of people and
just a different way of
climbing that I wasn't used to.
Mark and I summited Everest
together and when we came down
as we were walking out,
we're like, this is happening.
We're gonna make
Hkakabo Razi happen
and that's going to
be our next trip.
And it's going to
be anti-Everest
and it's gonna be an adventure.
( scoffs )
Little did we know.
( laughing )
So, the idea behind
it was to really explore
and travel over land and
find this mountain and...
take GPS's with us and
tag the summit and
see if it was really the highest
mountain in South East Asia.
So, planning the trip,
this is pretty much
what I had to work with.
And you can that the whole
mountain is blurred out
like it doesn't really exist.
Then the next thing is, you
know, you have to pick a team.
So, this had to
be a really unique team
because we were
going for two months
and there's probably only, like,
ten days of actual climbing.
So, first of all
getting a bunch of athletes
together is like herding cats.
They're all over the world,
all the time
and then we show up, you know,
in Tokyo with a zillion bags.
They all weighed
about 70 pounds and
we're used to Nepal standards
of 'you carry everything'.
You have jeans at base camp
and you have extra shoes
and flip flops and
a sun hat and...
We showed up with
all of that stuff.
It didn't last very long.
Um, quick video about us
getting into the country.
( instrumental music )
Usually on these trips
you definitely don't take
time to see a place so much
which is definitely a drawback
to a lot of expeditions.
Is you land in this
foreign place
but you just beeline
straight for the mountains.
( instrumental music )
-( bells ringing )
-( indistinct chatter )
All aboard!
( instrumental music )
Mark: Hilaree and I
conceived of this
as kind of the
anti-Everest trip.
We were coming off
of Everest together.
Been successful and
kind of wondered
"Okay, what's an old
fashioned expedition?"
Start in the capital
of the country
go over land all the
way to your mountain.
With this team, I think we have
as good a chance as anyone
of resolving
the mystery of
what's the highest
peaks in Burma.
( instrumental music )
Normally, as a climber, you just
you fly through
these countries and
you go straight
to the mountains
and it's actually a risk
to travel over land
because that's the
time when you get sick
you wear yourself
down unnecessarily.
But, none of us had
been to this country
and all of us
individually had spent
so much time in
Asia in general
that we wanted to really
experience the country
and that involved
going over land
which was about 1000
miles and we took about
every possible mode
of transportation,
you could imagine.
So, I had this like, romantic
notion of trains that is...
I think it doesn't
apply to this country.
This was a gentleman that we
thought was actually dead
when they were putting him
in there but he wasn't.
He was alive and he was, kind of
being passed through this window
to his family inside.
This is as the train started.
And I think from that expression
on my face this was early on.
And I was still thinking like
"Oh my Gosh, this is so great
like, wow, this is
gonna be amazing."
And then--
There's another video here
that will give you a better idea
of what the train was like.
Emily:
I would say this is
definitely another step
above the Everest trip.
More remote, more challenging
and the worst travel
experience I've ever had.
-( train car buckles )
-( screaming )
Literally you'd
be airborne and
then just slammed back
into your seat.
And then you'd be launched again
and slammed back into your seat.
Doing that for 18 hours just
sort of makes you insane.
Hilaree: We're on an adventure
and I think that was
what got me started in
expeditions in the first place.
Just this excitement for
the unknown.
I mean, the funny thing about
an adventure is that
you never know when the unknown
part is going to strike you.
And we learned later--
Taylor, who was the base
camp manager, she was like
"So, before we left, I was kind
of looking on the internet
and I found this thing that
the train in Burma is
called the Death train."
I was like,
"Why didn't you tell us that
before we got on the train?"
But, yeah, so that's, don't
ride the train in Burma.
So, the train
took us to Mytchina.
We're now in
the Kachin state.
And there is a little bit of
tribal fighting and everything
between Mytchina and Putao.
So, we were required to take
a domestic flight to Putao
which was kind of our
final destination
before we set out
for the mountain.
So, Putao, 205
miles to the mountain.
We just had our own feet
to get us there and motorcycles.
At this point, we were put
under town arrest in Putao.
And we arrived on a Friday
we were supposed to
leave on Saturday
we had our motorcycles ready
we had porters waiting
for us in the jungle
and we couldn't leave town.
And Mark and I were frantic,
we were running around
trying to talk to every
government official
anyone we could.
But, of course it was the
weekend and it was like
some random, weird holiday
and nobody would talk to us.
And finally, Monday afternoon
after we went through
government in Yangon
we finally got clearance.
But, we didn't actually--
we weren't actually able
to leave until Tuesday.
In the end, this four-day delay
caused a lot of strife
as the trip went on.
So, the day that we were cleared
to go, it started raining.
Of course!
And a lot of the motorcycle
drivers had left.
So, we ended up having to
confine a lot of our gear on a
on a smaller amount of bikes.
This was Taylor. She was on
the back of this guy's bike.
And um... I just
like this picture.
She was kind of miserable.
Um, and you'll see why here,
from this next video.
( sound of rain )
Hilaree: We finally got our
permissions yesterday.
We are packing up motorcycles,
that looks totally sketchy.
This is my driver...
he just cracked a beer
at 7:30 in the morning.
I'm gonna ride with him.
( motorcycle starts )
Got a 50-pound backpack and a
30-pound Movi in my right hand.
Not really sure how that's gonna
work, but, see how it goes.
( water splashing )
I mean, I don't know, it's
probably really hard driving
but I just feel like I have
the shittiest driver.
( instrumental music )
We're in
"Expedition 101" mode.
And it's definitely,
partly, you know...
my mistake.
I should've been
keeping better track of
where the bikes
were and everything.
But, right now, we're
getting pretty spread out.
On the way in we get 80 miles
on motorcycles in four days.
And then, we started
the jungle walk.
( insects buzzing )
When we were first getting
on the motorcycles
one of this driver--
one of the drivers looked at
me and I was wearing shorts.
And he was like, "Shorts?"
( audience laughter )
He's like, "Pants, you
should put on pants."
I was like, "Oh,
no, no, I'm fine.
It's super hot. I
don't like heat."
Um, so I went out the
first day in shorts.
I thought he meant, because
like you could get scratched
by bamboo or you know,
whatever.
But, instead I just
got completely mauled
by these no-see-ums.
So, there weren't mosquitos but
there were these gnats and bees.
All these bee stings.
I had hundreds of bites
just from that one day.
And I put shorts on, even that,
or pants,
like I had, you know those
trekker-zip on things
and I, I mean I put pants
on by the end of the day
because I kind of
finally figured it out
but it was already too late.
And, so this was my first
real test with suffering.
I mean, I live at 9,000
feet for a reason
because I don't
really like bugs.
I think, does anybody
ever feel like this?
Like if you have an intense
dislike of something
and then it seems to recur
over and over in your life.
Mine's like bugs and
snakes and spiders and--
I must have come across five
different snakes on the trek.
And this was the first one
that I almost stepped on
within like, two hours of
getting off the motorcycles
and walking on the trail.
There's a lot of
snakes in Burma.
Some leeches. Lots of
leeches in the area.
These actually were so
common and frequent that
they kind of became
inconsequential by the end.
But, the first time
we were hiking at night
through the jungle
and just coming down and
Emily got there before
me and she sat down.
I had this white shirt on and
she had her headlamp on and
I took my pack off and
I undid the buckle
And she looks up with
her headlamp and
the entire middle section of my
white shirt was soaked in blood.
And she screamed and
started freaking out
and it was from a leech.
Like, I had no idea,
I never even saw it.
And just, when they fall off
they put this sort of
anti-coagulant in you
and so you continue to bleed.
So, it didn't
hurt me or anything
but it looked so gruesome.
I thought Emily was going
to faint. ( laughs )
But, the one thing that
stood out was the water.
And I think this the reason
that none of use got sick was
because it was the clearest,
bluest best tasting water
I have ever seen
in my entire life.
And I think it's just because
this area is so untrammelled.
You had springs coming out of
the side of the hills that we--
you know, we had all these
water pumps and everything
that we just stopped using and
just drank the water straight
and it was incredible,
and none of us got sick.
So, going back to
that town arrest
the porters didn't wait for us,
for those four days, they left.
We didn't realize we were
coming right at harvest season.
So, they all went
back to the fields.
And so, this was a major issue
and we had enough
gear for 80 porters.
But, there's not
this porter history
like there is in Nepal
or India or Pakistan.
And so,
none of them really cared.
They thought we were
just crazy people
trying to get into a mountain
with way too much stuff.
So, at any given point, the most
we had was maybe 30 porters.
And what happened was
we had to make some really
tough decisions at this point.
And that was hang on to those
base camp booties and go home
or cut a lot of our gear.
We basically cut about
two-thirds of our gear.
At one point Renan
who's like this big man's
man was like, in tears.
Because he had to get rid
of all of his camera stuff.
I mean, the most incredible...
takeaway from this is
what Cory and Renan were able
to pull out as far as
video and photography
with literally sharing lenses
and two camera bodies
and nothing else.